bon sens à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au sommaire de ça vous regarde ce soir
quelle réponse européenne face à la
crise du coronavirus pourquoi les
vingt-sept peine autant à se coordonner
face à l'épidémie et que 17 en puissance
de l'état de l'union européenne et
l'italie l'italie bunkérisé ce soir est
ce scénario qui attend la france
coronavirus chacun sa méthode
c'est notre grand débat ce soir tribune
contre eux tribune sur les violences
sexuelles après la polémique née de la
cérémonie des césar le journal le monde
publie deux textes qui se revendiquent
tous les deux féministes le premier
rassemble des avocate pénaliste elle
défendre la présomption d'innocence et
la prescription un règlement déni de
réalité lui répond en substance le
second texte face à face de deux
signataires deux visions sur ce débat
hautement inflammable sur ce plateau
et puis notre grand témoin ce soir vient
publier un livre aussi intime que
nostalgique mi août chez flammarion
c'est quand on décide de couper le son
un jour fera mia n'a plus entendu sa
fille à la radio un jour sa fille n'a
plus entendu sa mère parle et c'est
cette double perte simultanée qu'elle
viendra nous raconter sur ce plateau la
journaliste pascale clark est avec nous
ce soir voilà donc pour le programme
c'est parti hashtag cvr n'oubliez pas on
y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir pascale
clark
bonsoir et bienvenue je suis ravi de
vous accueillir vous êtes une très
grande voix de la radio en france et une
journaliste qui a marqué ma génération
bienvenus france inter europe 1 rtl
canal+ et et j'en passe et vous publié
mi août chez flammarion on va en parler
longuement dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission c'est l'histoire d'un
double chagrin de deuil simultanées ont
en quelque sorte un carcan quand vous
cesser au fond de parler à la radio
votre mère a perdu ou perd
progressivement la parole après après
une maladie à cause d'une maladie on va
en parler tout à l'heure c'est un récit
intime et c'est un récit sur un
parallélisme de destin d'une certaine
manière c'est assez fascinant mais votre
regard de journaliste nous intéresse
aussi beaucoup ce soir femme engagée
également sur l'actualité et l'actualité
c'est toujours ce coronavirus avec deux
questions ce soit ce qui se passe en
italie serait-il possible en france dans
deux trois quatre semaines
et pourquoi l'europe n'agit pas d'une
seule voix on en parle avec vous patrick
martin grenier bonsoir je n'y ai
pardonné moi vous êtes professeur à
sciences po paris et spécialiste de
l'europe et puis avec vous frédéric
bizarre bon choix
non elle vous êtes économiste de la
santé et président de l'institut de
santé je vous donne la parole à tous les
trois dans un instant mais celui qui va
nous planter le décor de ce premier
débat pourquoi au fond l'europe est
désunie face à l'épidémie c'est stéphane
blakowski si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
avec entrée en plaine au bois rose à
toutes et à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris et myriam
l'union européenne finalement est pas si
unique ça faso coronavirus alors
évidemment si on s'en tient aux
déclarations officielles
là évidemment tout le monde plaide pour
la solidarité c'est évidemment notre
meilleure arme
nous européens pour affronter ce virus
d'ailleurs hier le président macro
envoyé un tweet pour justement lancé un
appel alors oui voilà il dit il dit bien
sûr qu'il faut agir ensemble ils
commencent même son pic par l'union fait
la force qui est la devise belge et on
est vraiment dans l'esprit aurait alors
est-ce qu'il a été entendu cet appel à
l'unité du président va se dire que vu
que l'esprit de solidarité européen est
inscrit dans les traités pas forcément
tout le monde est un peu d'accord du
monde plaident pour cet esprit de vérité
sauf qu'en réalité c'est parfois un peu
plus compliqué si on prend l'exemple de
la france par exemple d'un côté nous
disons à nos amis européens et agissons
ensemble enfin et de l'autre un exemple
le gouvernement a décidé de
réquisitionner tous les masques etc et
distant pense donc pas question pour
l'instant d'exporter des masques vers
d'autres pays européens qui en auraient
besoin alors on n'est pas les seuls les
allemands fait pareil
les tchèques l'ont fait aussi mais en
attendant la ministre belge de la santé
elle proteste un peu d'avoir un petit
tweet à son tour est libre est ce que
c'est ça est ce que c'est vraiment
solidaire qui est gardée des masques
pour soi dans ce n'est pas fidèle à
l'esprit de l'union européenne donc les
belges nous reproche au fond le chacun
pour soi mais alors le truc c'est que ça
va dans les deux sens parce que côté
français aussi on a des raisons de
s'agacer notamment parce que la séance
du parlement a été déplacée aujourd'hui
c'est la décision a été prise avant mais
elle a été déplacée de strasbourg à
bruxelles et alors ça ça n'a l'air de
rien mais arnaud danjean élus au
parlement européen républicain voilà
comment il réagit comme ça ridicule
scandaleux et irresponsables pourquoi il
s'énerve à ce point parce que il ya un
lobby qui chercheraient ce que le
parlement des ménages définitivement à
bruxelles et non pas à strasbourg par
les français aussi prothèse stocker des
bisbilles en fait pendant cette crise du
grenelle rsa imaginer qu'on s'en passe
un petit minet dans ce mode et bizzbee
mais à force qui est plein de petites
bisbilles ça fait un peu comme des
grains de sable boyer ne sait rien un
grand stade mais quand y'en a tellement
ça finit presque par la grippe et un
engrenage et notamment s'en rend compte
quand on compare aux états unis où les
décisions sont prises beaucoup plus vite
à la réserve fédérale la semaine
dernière a décidé de baisser les taux en
europe
c'est décidé cette semaine ça suffisait
pas ils ont donc remis des liquidités à
disposition et donc pendant ce temps là
que fait la bce la banque centrale
européenne
eh bien elle prend son temps elle
réfléchit à tel point que dirige breton
que les commissaires européens ce matin
et nous hier je pense au rock était un
peu impatient de la voir agir
la priorité c'est le faire en sorte que
les acteurs économiques les banques
puissent avoir les liquidités
suffisantes les mettre à disposition des
pme de façon rapide et c'est évidemment
sur ce terrain que nous attendons la bce
et je ne doute pas que c'est ce qu'elle
fera et qu'elle le fera vite
ouais donc ça urge très vite bon en
attendant les états membres où ils
préparent chacun leur plan de relance
un chacun a fait sa son petit plan de
relance en sont dingues et sur personne
n'est resté sans agir on a vu en france
des mesures pour les impôts des modes et
des délais pour payer les charges
sociales pareil en allemagne pareil en
italie fans d'arrêter de mesures n'y a
pas la mesure qui coordonne l'ensemble
au niveau européen pourtant le 4 mars
les ministres des finances de l'union
européenne se sont réunis
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont décidé à l'issue de
cette réunion en regardant le site
euractiv quel site spécialisé dans
l'actualité européenne eba ils ont
décidé le 4 mars qu'il était urgent
d'attendre
combien de temps ça va durer l'inaction
encore une fois chacun réagit de son
côté alors il ya quelques rendez vous
prévu alors le 12 donc c'est jeudi il ya
une conférence de presse de la bce la
banque européenne donc on attend des
décisions puis le 16
donc lundi prochain il ya une réunion
des ministres des finances ont une
nouvelle réunion
mais cette fois ci ses premiers bruno le
maire est bien décidé à taper du poing
sur la table
on écoute je proposerai une série de
mesures fiscales budgétaires permettant
de définir un plan de relance européen
coordonné et massif qui nous permettra
de relancer la machine économique
au lendemain de la crise il faut
attendre quoi encore cinq jours avant
qu'un grand plan droit cinq jours pour
les mini et puisqu'ils vont se fait
retomber d'accord je ne sais pas où on
va on attend on attend et finalement la
question qu'on se pose en attendant
c'est cette crise qui était censée
prouver que la solidarité de l'union
européenne faisait sa force
ban inverse sur ce qu'on est en train de
se prouver une fois de plus que quand
une crise arrive on n'est pas très
solidaire se poser la question tout de
suite patrick martin gène j vous le
comprenez il vous surprend cet
attentisme européens face à cette crise
alors moi je suis un peu réservé sur
cette notion d'attentisme européen pour
plusieurs raisons la première il faut
pas trop technocratique me faut savoir
une chose c'est que la santé ne fait pas
partie des compétences de l'union
européenne il y à plus de 350 articles
dans ce traité sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne a qu'un qui parle de
la santé si l'article 168 et que dit cet
article il dit qu'on doit respecter
l'indépendance des états
ce sont eux qui déterminent leur
politique de santé ce qui alloue les
ressources sur les hôpitaux qui
détermine les budgets par conséquent la
politique de santé est de la seule
responsabilité de l'unio des états de
l'europe et c'est pour ça qu'on a la
sensation aujourd'hui que chacun réponde
de façon un peu dispersés en fonction de
ses propres caractéristiques de son
système hospitalier système différent
c'était en matière de santé en attendant
c'est là c'est la récession qui me l'a
alors oui alors chose c'est que nous ne
sommes pas encore
enfin il ya les deux on est d'abord dans
une phase sanitaires et l'union
européenne a quand même mis en place un
mécanisme il y à une qu'une cellule de
crise à la commission européenne qui
regroupe cinq commissaires et il a été
décidé d'allouer tout de suite
immédiatement 45 millions d'euros pour
un appel à projets pour les recherches
de leur chef le vaccin ce la recherche
le vaccin mais qui doivent être doublés
par des participations des industries
pharmaceutique donc il y à un
partenariat entre les industries
pharmaceutique et la commission
européenne je dis pas que ça va suffire
mais c'est un élément qui montre que la
commission qu'on ne te compte tenu de
ses compétences se mobilise maintenant
vous avez raison de souligner que sur le
plan économique on a dit qu'il était
urgent d'attendre parce que il faut voir
les conséquences économiques que cela va
être et cela entraîne des conséquences à
des bac on n'a jamais pu avoir avant
parce que comme vous savez par exemple
l'allemagne n'est pas forcément d'accord
ni les pays du nord sur la relance que
souhaite la france donc c'est une
occasion pour relancer un débat
économique et vous avez raison de
souligner que je dis se réunit le
conseil des gouverneur à la banque
centrale européenne mais certains
économistes je passe au bout contre
votre contrôle disque
au final la banque centrale européenne a
comme
fait des efforts en matière de taux
d'intérêt et qu'elle ne pourra pas faire
grand chose d'autre donc voilà donc oui
les allemands sont pas d'accord et
russes et les allemands sont pas
d'accord donc il ya deux aspects
l'aspect sanitaire
l'europe n'a pas beaucoup de compétences
mal va essayer de coordonner et enfin
l'aspect économique où effectivement il
était peut être urgent d'attendre avant
de savoir quelles sont les conséquences
économiques et boursières de cette crise
a dit eric bizarre vous voyez les choses
comme ça au fond le retard peut-être
nous choque un peu mais il peut
s'expliquer alors monsieur appuyé est un
spécialiste de ces questions il ya
évidemment parfaitement raison la santé
ne fait pas partie des compétences
communautaires la santé n'est pas dans
les traités on les traitait mentionne
juste qu'il faut essayer d'atteindre le
plus haut degré de santé possible dans
la population n'ont donc et on a vu que
la réunion des ministres de la santé de
l'année dernière a été un désastre
absolu puisque tout le monde est reparti
en constatant que ce communiqué aucune
décision n'avait rien de rien quand on
voit que les masques sont réquisitionnés
chacun pour soi quand on voit qu'à un
manque de solidarité dans l'urne est là
et même pour une éventuelle conserver la
question allez rire l'économie question
elle est politique elle est politique il
n'ya pas de voulons qu'il n'y a pas eu
de volonté politique pour construire
l'europe de la santé donc à partir de là
devant vous n'avez pas de technique
maintenant une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
pose quand même un problème majeur
d'attractivité de l'europe de savoir ce
qu'on a construit véritablement l'europe
s'est construit avant tout sur une base
économique sur une base de créer un
libre marché à l'échelle européenne pour
le faire bon on essaie de construire
cette europe sociale ce qu'on voit là
c'est qu'on a eu le break sites et ces
cons on a quand même un problème
d'attractivité et d'image de l'europe
qui est quand même amplifiée par la
crise qu'on voit là parce que cette
crise finalement elle ne fait que
amplifier un certain nombre de choses
qui qui est qu'ils étaient prêts
existants qui existait on voit qu'on est
trop dépendant de l'asie en a en matière
de chaînes de production pour un certain
nombre de choses on voit qu'il ya une
solidarité quand même
l'europe qui est relativement fragile
bref donc on voit que c'est un
amplificateur par rapport à ça on a créé
des choses en europe et c'est toujours
intéressant on a créé le e le cdc
european center for disease prevention
and control c'est à dire le
une grande agence de santé publique
comme il ya aux états unis mais qui est
une coquille vide
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait le budget à
l'échelle de l'europe fatalement qui
était guidé les chats s'appelle andrea
mono début de la jante en les membres il
faisait on a créé le l'organisation des
oms organisation mondiale de la santé
s'est créée après la grippe espagnole
on avait créé un comité international
yann et puis ça s'est transformé en
dessous donc soit fait dans toute crise
il ya deux choses il ya un risque et il
ya des opportunités il ya des gens qu'il
ya des gens il ya des institutions il ya
des pays qui ont bon sens alors enfin
c'est l'économie de la santé que vous
êtes mais l'économiste tout court si
j'ose dire oui alors ou de l'arl aux iem
chose 2e g le veut la crise financière
déjà absolu qu'est un retard à la
décision
là il faut soutenir l'économie
européenne mais si nous ne sommes pas
une fédération d'états comme les
etats-unis le son avec une une
fédération avec une banque centrale qui
est qui est toujours beaucoup plus
réactive mais en effet pour le plan
d'urgence économique c'est un plan
d'urgence sanitaire qui n'est pas fait à
l'échelle européen qui est fait à
l'échelle des états mais on pourrait
attendre qu'ils aient un plan d'urgence
économique qui soit fait alors qu'il
vient de l'avertir que c'est un pari
mais ça a été mentionné le problème le
problème qu'on a c'est qu'on a déjà une
politique monétaire extrêmement
accommodante où on déverse 20 à 30
milliards de liquidités chaque mois est
en fait c'est la stratégie qu'il faut
avoir
donc on est sans rentrer d'autres
détails mais on est dans un problème de
trappes de liquidités c'est qu'en fait
vous avez déjà des liquidités et
réinjecter des liquidités ne va pas
relancer l'investissement dont ce n'est
pas forcément une solution à terme donc
en fait ce qui se passe parce qu'il faut
essayer d'expliquer les choses c'est
qu'en fait on est on n'attend qu'à
l'échelle de chaque pays
cueillez une aide parce que l'urgence
c'est l'accompagnement des entreprises
qui vont être en difficulté sur le court
terme sur le plan des trésoreries sont
payants des décalages
ça se fait à l'échelle je dirais d'aidé
des états et donc il faut quand même
essayer d'évaluer avec suffisamment de
recul
la situation économique à l'échelle
européenne pour que l'union européenne
puisse arriver avec un plan parce que
vous pourriez agit
mais avec un plan qui n'est pas efficace
et finalement c'est un breton il réclame
carrément plus de liquidités ça veut
dire que l'huile à l'instant qui manque
c'est un dispensaire jouer la branche et
refinancer pour qu'elle puisse prouver
leur mais j'aimerais vous faire réagir
je sais que vous n'êtes pas spécialiste
la citoyenne qui regarde au fond cette
crise sanitaire européenne et au fond ce
retard à l'allumage ce manque de
solidarité aussi injuste jusqu'à
m'étonne c'est que vous en seriez étonné
c'est à dire que l'europe ne soit pas
directv solidaire ni facile à bouger etc
c'est vraiment pas une surprise
malheureusement on a eu beaucoup au coût
de 2,2 d'exemples dans le passé
donc si elle arrive à se coordonner pour
venir à bout l'urgence est d'abord
sanitaire avant d'être économique elle
est aussi économique parce qu'il va y
avoir malheureusement beaucoup de
victimes
sur le plan économique enfin les d'abord
jusqu'à nouvel ordre sanitaires et est
donc ce serait vraiment une surprise que
ce l'union européenne parviennent à
s'accorder là où elle ne s'est jamais
accordé par exemple pour le sort des
migrants voyez ce qui est quand même un
exemple mon gars il ya une sorte voilà
deux précédents dans l'histoire qui nous
amène oui à l'europe où nous sommes tous
d'accord v une crise d'identité
on refuse d'aller plus loin sur
l'identité politique de l'europe ça
c'est certain
on n'est plus dans une période d père
fondateur de l'europe on pouvait lancer
des projets solidaires une union
politique désormais c'est chacun pour
soi et regarder aussi avec la montée du
populisme
je regardais monsieur salvini avait
encore en italie une réunion aujourd'hui
que le président du conseil en disant il
faut fermer toutes les frontières
il n'y a plus de solidarité mais
l'intérêt aujourd'hui de cette crise
sanitaire
c'est qu'il va y avoir un véritablement
un débat politique sur ce qu'on peut
faire pour renverser un sursaut et
l'europe parce qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple on en train de dire il va
falloir aider les industries et ne pas
les mettre dans cette notion dette
d'état prohibé par la commission
européenne à mon sens et grâce aux
techniques
la commission européenne la banque
centrale européenne quel traitement de
choc là maintenant il va y avoir quand
même des décisions vont être prises
bah le traitement de choc disons ça ça
relève des ministres d'économies vous
citiez monsieur le maire tout à l'heure
ils vont dire il faut même un paquet
d'argent dans l'économie il faut que la
banque centrale
on descend relatif mais si c'est à dire
qu'on pourrait aider des entreprises en
grande difficulté sans que la commission
européenne par des êtres direction que
la commission européenne vient de mettre
son nez dans cette affaire pour parler
simplement et certains parlent
éventuellement de ne plus respecter pour
cent pour cent de déficit et faire les
temps il ya deux choses à faire il ya
déjà et ça a été fait c'était de ne pas
considérer que toutes les dépenses
supplémentaires viendront ne viendront
pas ne seront pas comptabilisé dans le
déficit grec ça on les sort donc ça ça a
été dit ensuite c'est ce qu'on appelle
le quantitative easing c'est à dire que
vous faites des rachats massifs
d'obligations pour alléger la dette des
entreprises parce que vous avez une
un des problèmes c'est que vous avez des
entreprises qui sont à l'échelle
mondiale extrêmement endettée on est à
peu près 85 % du pib mondial en niveau
d'endettement et donc d'ailleurs le fmi
avait attiré l'attention il ya trois
mois en disant qu'il y avait 40 % le 7
date qui était à risque s'il y avait une
baisse d'activité économique on est en
plein dedans
donc on voit qu'il va y avoir énormément
de daya il ya un vrai risque sur le plan
de l'endettement des entreprises donc là
il va y avoir les messieurs breton
l'heureux à juste titre le réclame le
seul problème c'est qu'on a déjà injecté
des milliards et des milliards de
liquidités donc on était déjà un petit
peu au bout de cette logique a changé
sur au moins deux principes d'heures
qu'ils sont ce que vous disiez ne pas
accorder des aides parce que cela
fausserait la concurrence et
entraînement ne jamais faire trop de
déficit est ce que c'est pas le moment
ces deux points de la les sursauts pour
remettre une bonne et air india sera
toujours ça se rembourse toujours sûr on
n'aura pas la réponse à ces questions là
on va attendre ce conseil ou pas je
voudrais quand même dans ce débat abordé
l'autre question du jour c'est l'italie
qui aurait pu imaginer ça au coeur de
l'europe
restez chez vous c'est le message du
président conté à l'ensemble de la
population du pays mesures drastiques à
l'appui un pays sous cloche et des
médecins en proie à des dilemmes
absolument cornélien dans les hôpitaux
tout cela nous a résumé par clément
perdre un pays entier à l' isolement
c'est une mesure sans précédent qu'a
annoncé hier soir le président du
conseil italien giuseppe comptes à ok
sauf film à aller au progrès des mais je
suis sur le point de signer un décret
que l'on peut résumer ainsi
je reste chez moi y'aurait soit case le
scénario italien est il celui qui attend
la france
le virus est pour l'heure beaucoup plus
répandue en italie mais sa courbe
d'évolution semble prendre un chemin
similaire à huit jours d'intervalle
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
insiste pourtant pour bien distinguer
les deux situation et les décisions que
l'italie prend sur une partie de son
territoire sont clairement liés à la
saturation des urgences à saturation de
ses réanimation c'est un territoire
italien très particulier avec une
population âgée isolée où les formes
graves sont plus nombreuses qu'ailleurs
on ne peut pas comparer toutes les
situations dès le début de la crise
l'italie a pourtant pris des mesures
bien plus spectaculaire que la france
contre le coronavirus des villages
entiers complètement coupé du monde des
limitations de déplacements drastique
des prises de température massive dans
les gares et aéroports pour un effet
finalement limité l'italie a fermé ses
aéroports et interdit les voyages en
provenance de chine que la france ne
l'avaient pas fait et elle a été touchée
avant la france et plus rapidement et
plus sévèrement que la france ça montre
bien que cette disposition était
violente et que son utilité s'il en a eu
une elle était très modeste
ces différences entre france et italie
le montrent les plans d'action face au
virus ne sont pour l'instant pas
coordonnés entre états européens
j'accueille richard vers lui qui nous a
rejoint ben soir richard vous d'être le
correspondant parisien du quotidien
suisse le temps et chroniqueur dans
cette émission 9 9172 cas de
contamination en italie fraude avec
blizzard 463 morts ce soit 60 millions
au fonds d'italiens assigné à résidence
est justifiée franchement alors il faut
comprendre pourquoi si ces dernières
font ça c'est la stratégie du désespoir
de dernier de dernier ressort
ils le font parce que comme les chinois
ils ont raté la première étape qui est
le confinement individuel pour
différentes raisons les chinois l'ont
faibles ont raté parce qu'ils ont plutôt
essayé d'étouffer les premiers cas est
plutôt de s'occuper des lanceurs d'alert
que des mots que des malades
donc après ça a été trop tard donc il
fallait mettre les patients 0 les
patients 0 donc avoir une contrôle et on
trouve les plus la chaîne de
contamination dont vous êtes obligé de
mettre sous cloche le foyer qui existe
et il est arrivé la même chose pour des
raisons différentes en italie c'est à
dire que vous avez eu deux régions la
lombardie et la vénétie qui ont été
touchés et qu'ils ont tardé à réagir il
faut savoir que le système de santé
italien et décentraliser ce sont les
compétences sont à la chaîne des régions
région depuis la loi 1999 il se trouve
que ces deux régions en plus sont
dirigés par la ligue du nord qui n'a pas
les meilleures relations avec le
gouvernement actuel long qui a plutôt
essayé de gérer sa part elle même sans
avoir un plan très coordonnée et
finalement ça n'a pas fonctionné
il ya du positif dans l'émetteur de
toujours répéter donc à partir de là eux
aussi n'ont pas réussi à contrôler les
premiers cas la chaîne de contamination
et donc on dit mais tu n'en ont dû
passer d'un confinement individuel ce
qu'on a fait en france pourrait revenir
à un confinement collectif à l'échelle
de villes entières
le seul problème c'est que ça ne marche
pas en s'aidant de fluides et décédé en
confinement collectif non plus mais non
pourquoi pas ce que vous avez toujours
des fuites vous empêchez pas les gens
oui pour des raisons professionnelles
pour des raisons personnelles vont
partir et qui peuvent s'avérer llaneza
mondiale et à rester mais aussi peu
importe ça ne s'annonçait qui ne cessa
de trois mois de prison 210 euros
d'amendé a dit ça limite c'est pour ça
que c'est une stratégie quand vous
n'avez pas le choix elle est ce que
disait
ministres verront c'est qu'il ya un
moment donc ils ont saturé leur système
de santé
le système est donc il ya un moment
qu'est ce que vous faites vous ne pouvez
plus protéger les populations vous
pouvez plus soigner les gens donc vous
prenez ce qui certes ne n'est pas
efficace mais est quand même plus
efficace que de ne rien faire vous
confiné toute la population dont qu'ils
en sont là encore une fois par par
défaut de pouvoir faire autre chose
qu'aux questions questions rapides et je
vous donne la parole déjà notre système
de santé français n'est pas comparable à
l'organisation déjà alors attention
parce que je vois beaucoup quand même
d'assez d'autosatisfaction mais ça on
est assez doué pour ça comme quoi en
france on est le deuxième pays le plus
touché d'europe il ya d'autres qui n'en
soit pas où on en est on on n'est pas au
cas italien mais on n'est pas les
allemands les espagnols votent ils ont
pas bon deuxième chose bien sûr qu'on a
on a un risque de saturation notamment
nous on a cinq mille places de
réanimation c'est le maillon sensible à
la réanimation qui est déjà le cas de
soins intensifs et puis vous avez celle
de réanimation quand vous êtes obligés
de mettre donc sous assistance
respiratoire nasa 1000 places qui sont
déjà avec un taux d'occupation important
parce qu'il ya toujours des des malades
donc donc nous on a ce maillon faible
qui existe mais ce qu on a alors d'abord
la france est un pays qui en a les
qualités de nos défauts c'est qu'on est
extrêmement centralisé mais quand vous
avez comme ça une attaque virale il vaut
mieux avoir une réaction relativement
centralisée au début pour avoir des
plans très coordonnée à l'échelle
centrale donc on a réussi ce confinement
individuelles qu'on a poussé le plus
longtemps possible et qu'on essaie
encore de pousser le plus longtemps
possible c'est à dire que on repère les
gens qui sont malades
on les confine et puis on va voir tous
les patients contact pour essayer
eux-mêmes de les confiner
donc en fait on n'a pas eu cette flambée
épidémique ont eu les les italiens très
rapidement donc nous nous avons le temps
de nous préparer à sa contamination par
dont 800 4104 contamination mais
l'elysée dans pardonnez-moi mais ciblée
si on prend juste la réanimation sur
simple pour que saturé cinq mille 5000
places de réanimation il faut qu'on ait
plus qu'il ya peu près 10% de des gens
qui sont hospitalisés oui il faut qu'on
ait des centaines de milliers de cas
donc donc on est quand même assez
protégé à ça donc ça on a réussi c'est
pour ça qu'on est un dieu maintenant à
partir de là
le cette centralisation de la réaction
et de la gestion de la crise à mon avis
à ses limites aujourd'hui parce que ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut éviter c'est
donc qu'il y ait une contamination trop
importante et je pense qu'il faut avant
tout protéger
pascale clark a dit un mot essentiel
toys et sanitaires qui l'emportent
mais c'est le sanitaire c'est la
protection des gens donc il faut
protéger les plus les plus fragiles et
celui pas de dire aux personnes âgées
on va pas aller vous voir les personnes
les plus fragiles c'est pas que les
personnes âgées sont les personnes qui
ont des comorbidités qui ont des
affections de longue durée qui sont très
bien connus du système donc moi je pense
qu'il faut passer à une phase davantage
avec en mobilisant les forces vives et
après je vous laisse je voulais les
forces vives type type les caisses
primaires d'assurance-maladie type les
associations de patients qui il faut
avoir un plan je pense extrêmement plus
ciblées sur les personnes les plus
fragiles et plutôt laisser un espace de
liberté important aux autres et martin
gêné comment cela si tu as bien bas ils
sont un peu résigné si vous voulez parce
qu'ils y est et non pas trop de
réflexion si c'est la seule solution ils
veulent pas non plus qu'on critique trop
leur système j'étais avec un ami italien
avant-hier il n'aimait pas qu'on
critique il est allé mais vous l'avez
souligné tout à fait justement on
parlait de que chaque pays est face à
ses responsabilités mais chaque pays a
la responsabilité de son propre service
public hospitalier et ça fait des années
j'ai été voir dans la presse il ya pas
longtemps ça fait des années qu'on
critique l'organisation hospitalière
italienne pour c'est insuffisant je dis
pas que nous on est les meilleurs
mais il ya des insuffisances des
dysfonctionnements tout à fait noir est
resté non et il n'y a pas eu de
réflexion politique aussi sur
l'éventuelle constitutionnalité ou
inconstitutionnalité d'un tel décret qui
à mon avis ne tient pas la rue reste que
ce décret je reste je reste chez moi qui
confie de lentilles un entièreté de
l'italie pour moi ce n'est pas
conventionnel par rapport à la
convention européenne est trop d'hommes
et de surcroît ce n'est pas
nécessairement efficaces parce que la
veille de la mise en oeuvre
l'application du décret de giuseppe côté
le président du conseil
il ya beaucoup d'italiens qui ont fui
qui sont partis dans d'autres régions
dont certains sont arrivés d'ailleurs en
france il n'y a pas de contrôles aux
frontières entre l'italie et la france
je ne critique pas mais le fait est que
cette mesure à mon sens n'est pas
particulièrement efficace je crains
qu'on est encore malheureusement rien vu
en italie puisque quand le
sud de la péninsule sera touché là ça
risque de faire mal parce qu'on sait
c'est connu notoirement que les voilà le
sud à un système hospitalier bien moins
bien moins au point que le nord donc
mais fragile quand même du mal à
comprendre cette disparité quand même
énorme
le bars et trois quarts ont peut-être
davantage des cas européens sont en
italie et est-ce qu'on est si bien nous
traiter le foyer 0 à creil j'ai pas
l'impression donc j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre cette disparité et cette
particularité oui mais il n'y a pas
autant de morts il ya une réactivité du
service qos boj des amis infectiologues
sont dans les hôpitaux qui me disent on
a des réunions dallaire tous les jours
on a des chambres confiné on est prêt à
accueillir des gens et heureusement il
n'ya pas aussi folle que ça et j'ai
écouté aujourd'hui le ministre de la
santé allemand se sont réunis ils ont
dégagé tout de suite à milliards d'euros
pour y injecter dans l'axé quand même
les médecins oui dans l'est dans les
hôpitaux on est comme dans une économie
de guerre quoi quand on choisit entre
ceux qui jouent à survivre ça fait
partie de notre métier est effectivement
en cas de bain d'attentats autre chose
comme ça notre métier c'est de choisir
malheureusement alors quand on le
signale ça fait froid dans le dos et je
crois que malheureusement c'est la
partie de leur quotidien aux urgences
rassurez-nous quand même s'il vous plaît
en ce qui concerne la france la rapidité
de la propagation de ce virus
comparaison entre france italie mais
aussi en nous on essaye de contenir
c'est la fameuse coupe qu'à montrer aux
différents on essaye de la faire alors
mais elle est et c'est toujours cette
courbe la cinétique des est à dire le
développement des décontaminations est
toujours en effet avec ses cette courbe
en cloche mais la caisse personne ne
peut savoir le président a dit nous
sommes qu'au début très honnêtement
c'est place est une hypothèse parmi
d'autres ya des scénarios prend des
scénarios non la question encore une
fois il faut savoir quand même que cet
agent il va les infectiologues sont tous
d'accord là dessus il est quand même
assez peu pathogène il pourrait
davantage de devenir où il pourra encore
être moins pathogène donc il faut quand
même rassuré la population qu'à partir
du moment où vous n'avez pas de
déficience particulière vous pouvez en
avoir une vie normale
en revanche encore une fois si vous avez
un certain nombre de pathologies
existantes
il faut particulièrement bien se
protéger
80 combien 98 % des patients guérissent
en france ces derniers temps
non non ça c'est vous avez en gros vous
avez 10 à 15 pour allant de personnes
qui sont hospitalisées
donc vous avez 85 pour ce pauvre je
crois que c'est ce qu'est ce qu'a dit le
président 85 % des personnes pour lequel
la pathologie et bening richard etter
voulu nous parler ce soir de
l'interdépendance des hôpitaux notamment
aux frontières laisser passer les
soignants est absolument et je suis venu
vous dire que l'europe existe parce que
j'entends dire depuis tout à l'heure
qu'il n'existe pas elle existe le poste
dans des endroits bien précis qui rament
les clubs européens visioconférence mais
en ce moment il aimait me lie à cette
visioconférence mais il y a beaucoup
d'hôpitaux vous le savez dans des zones
frontalières et ses hôpitaux ils ont
besoin de soignants souvent qui viennent
d'autres pays par exemple en allemagne
il y à des infirmiers ou des médecins
alsaciens qui vont travailler en italie
on le disait tout à l'heure notamment
lombardi beaucoup vont travailler dans
le tessin en suisse et d'ailleurs la
suisse qui est un pays réputé être
particulièrement sourcilleux sur ses
frontières vient de demander
officiellement l'italie de continuer de
laisser passer ces soignants et ça je
trouve que c'est très intéressant parce
que ça prouve une chose c'est d'abord
que l'idée de fermer les frontières dont
on a beaucoup parlé dont certains
continuent en temps de parler et bien il
serait extrêmement négatif parce qu'elle
priverait certains hôpitaux de forces
vives dont on a besoin pour affronter
l'épidémie et cela prouve aussi que à un
moment donné il faut savoir réguler les
flux comme vous le disiez il faut
arriver une solidarité européenne
emmanuel macron lui il a beaucoup poussé
pour sa part exemple certes il ya eu ces
réquisitions de stocks de masques
respiratoires
mais on apprend qu'il est peut-être
possible que des entreprises européennes
du secteur de la santé qui actuellement
fabrique d'autre chose que des masques
mais avec des matériels comparables puis
se reconvertir et se met à fabriquer ces
masses donc il ya véritablement une
coordination européenne à mettre en
place et elle est quand même en train de
se mettre en place et enfin dernière
chose sur les soignants et il faut le
dire c'est que quand on ouvre les
frontières ont permis aussi aux
scientifiques d'échangé on permet au
laboratoire de travailler plus
rapidement on permet aux diagnosticien
aux urgentistes de comparer les
échantillons d'une région à l'autre dans
deux pays différents
autrement dit on
permet un étalonnage et une meilleure
connaissance de la maladie au niveau
européen donc cela prouve une chose
c'est que la liberté de circulation
elle est aussi la liberté de soigner et
pas seulement la liberté pour le virus
de circuler merci cher on va s'arrêter
là sur cette note plus optimiste la
liberté de soigner pour l'intérêt
collectif des européens que nous sommes
et des humains après tout sur cette
planète merci messieurs le coronavirus
prend évidemment énormément de place
dans les médias il vampirise au passage
une élection une élection qui a lieu
dans cinq jours j'ai nommé les
municipales cette semaine
lcp s'arrête à rouen avec des habitants
des élus des associations
la ville reste évidemment profondément
marqué par l' incendie lusine lubrizol
c'était en septembre dernier rouen sous
le nuage c'est une série de nathalie
gloire et françois chevret premier
épisode regarder
[Musique]
sophie est enseignante elle habite le
centre ville de rouen et le 26 sept ans
quand elle ouvre sa fenêtre elle
aperçoit un épais nuage noir
lusine chimique lubrizol vient de
prendre feu alors moi j'habite juste là
ici au quatrième as et la vue de mon
balcon au quatrième étage
le matin de l' incendie donc on voit les
bus les bus qui passent au même moment
et ce gros nuage noir qui qui recouvre
le centre ville c'était très très
angoissant toute la matinée
plus de 3000 substances hautement
toxiques brûle les rouennais reste
plusieurs heures sous le nuage noir sans
aucune information très vite se fit
prend la décision de quitter la ville
avec sa famille
il a fallu une heure vraiment pour me
dire non mais finalement il faut il faut
faire quoi faut pas rester ici je sais
pas ce que ça va donner j'ai pris ma
petite fille dans la voiture et on a fui
à trouville on a la chance d'avoir des
vanniers labaki nous retraite à un
logement et on n'est pas rentrés avant
un mois
cette histoire ne laisse pas ses
consignes en inde m aujourd'hui elle
veut quitter la ville de rouen et a déjà
fait une demande de mutation
autre changement son vote aux élections
municipales
avant elle voté pour le parti socialiste
cette fois ci ce sera pour le candidat
écologiste de lubrizol va orienter mon
vote
comme vous pouvez le roi n'ait droit
neige j'attends un maire qui prennent
un peu plus en considération notre
environnement de vie
le cadre de vie est ce que c'est à la
ville de s'adapter aux usines mais ce
que ces halles usine de s'adapter à la
nina aujourd'hui encore les roannais ont
l'impression que l'état leur cache des
choses
alors certains citoyens ont décidé de se
mobiliser à l'image de simon de carvalho
le coprésident des sinistrés de lubrizol
que nous retrouverons demain on est
beaucoup moins d'avoir porté plainte
parce que c'est pas normal ce qui s'est
passé pascale clark on parle de votre
livre dans un tout petit instant ces
municipales comme citoyenne on n'avait
jamais vu un truc pareil
complètement écrasée par la crise du
cornet virus est ce que vous trouvez
qu'on en parle assez ou des musicales là
oui on a bien parlé quand même j'ai
l'impression de maintenant à cette
période
cinq jours avant ne parle que de ça là
on a vraiment vu ben vous connaissez la
r6 que format disant qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire l'effet de masse effet
l'effet masse des medias je sais pas si
justifiée faudrait faudrait soupeser je
pense que les gens sont au courant quand
même que dimanche et le premier tour et
il ya beaucoup non non moi j'ai
l'impression de voir des images de gens
qui tracte mais mettez elles sont
envahies de gens qui tracte c'est vrai
que les gens sur le terrain mais tlc mes
tweets line with ceux qui n'auraient pas
twitter non non mais ça va être très
intéressant après comprennent pas la
cause du courant des virus ne pas aller
voter parce que ça se tient pas le coup
franchement c'est bien que s'il ya une
grosse
abstention ce qui peut toujours arriver
on va dire c'est la faute aux
coronavirus et ce sera pas une bonne
excuse me semble utile
on verra ça sur sur lcp soirée
électorale dimanche prochain on va
parler de vous on va parler de votre
livre on va sélectionner aller quelques
oeufs sont écoutés bonjour antoine de
caunes non parce que le club
comment vous êtes vous retrouvé dans
cette embrouille présenter le grand
journal sur canal à la rentrée bonjour
eric dupond-moretti votre première
plaidoirie aline c'était quand c'était
en 1984 gagné perdu au perdu au il faut
commencer par là bonjour vous allez au
bonjour marine le pen envisage de ne
plus rembourser les ivg en cas de choix
budgétaires ça veut dire quoi
mais ça veut dire d'abord que c'est pas
tout à fait ce qu'elle a dit c'est vous
qui avez utilisé le terme d'usagers de
confort vous pouvez me regarder dans les
yeux et réemployés cette expression
c'est dégueulasse et voilà clark
je vous donne la parole dans deux
secondes mais je voudrais quand même
accueillir nos invités parce qu'on va
parler avec vous de cette tribune dans
le monde traite avec beaulieu pont soir
m vous êtes avocate pénaliste je viens à
vous d'en en quelques secondes et millet
comme maya bonsoir vous avez signé vous
une autre tribune dont on parlera dans
quelques instants
ce qu'on entend la sefee un style que
vous aviez s'est pas seulement une voix
tout le monde parle de vote voit ce
grain est inévitable une présence mais
c'est aussi un style c'est aussi une
répartie cd silence est une manière très
voilà précisé parfois un peu sharp comme
on dit en anglais est d'arriver à
trouver le mot qui va refaire rebondir
alors ça dépend de copains parce qu'il
beaucoup de forme d'une interview
différente si on entend louis aliot et
le dégueulasse qui est sorti comme ça à
la fin c'est l'engagement d' la femme
que vous énoncez journée c'est pas un
engagement ça devrait être tout le monde
devrait dire aux ong toujours le fn que
dire ivg de confort c'est oui c'est
l'expression est dégueulasse et c'est
pas être engagée que dès qu'on manque un
peu de courage nous les journalistes
parce que je suis pas courageuse mais
c'est vraiment ça enfin qui est-ce qui
quelle femme se dire tiens c'est pas
grave chansons que je vais vous
apportera c'est pas grave non ça
n'existe pas allégé de confort donc il
faut juste le rappeler et puis en plus
après coup on a su que c'était juste une
façon pour marine le pen d'être de tuer
l'opposition interne donc on joue quand
même avec le dessein divin n'a pas
raccroché
si bien sûr que si bah oui on l'a
reproché mais après je c'est sorti comme
ça c'était spontané
voilà je peux comprendre qu'on me le
reproche mais moi je défends
oui quand on a un interview quand on a
sa place au micro et bien les moyens de
dire de jouer au delà cela est-ce que
vous avez conscience d'avoir inventé
quelque chose à la radio non j'ai pas
cette conscience là enfin ce serait
extrêmement prétentieux de ma part que
de le dire tout ce que je peux vous
répondre c'est que j'ai fait attention
de changer souvent démission parce que
je pense qu'on s'ennuie ou d'un moment
et consent croûte et que oui j'étais ma
volonté a toujours été tenté des choses
mais parce que je trouve le direct là on
parle du direct ça se mérite et qu' on
ne peut pas dormir pendant direct et on
ne peut pas ne pas se remettre en cause
donc j'ai eu cette volonté là ça c'est
vrai on entend votre voix ou vous n'avez
pas beaucoup fait télévisions et à
canal+ en aparté bien sûr et on with on
ne voyait pas bien sûr mais il ya la
musique aussi vous avez énormément sur
mettre en valeur justement comment une
interview peut se faire aussi en musique
ça c'est de vos apports très peu l'ont
fait qu'est ce que la radio vous vous a
apporté
vous tous tous faut dire que j'ai eu un
coup de foudre pour la radio en même
temps que je voulais être journaliste
donc j'ai essayé de croiser les deux
plusieurs décennies d'antenne au
quotidien souvent et c'est une drogue
dure
on était très bien dans wii parce que
c'est un livre sur cette coïncidence qui
en est peut-être pas une
vous quittez la radio vous cessez de
parler et au même moment quasiment votre
mère fragnes à elle va aussi cesser de
parler oui cirque on a chuté en même
temps je m'en suis pas rendu compte
immédiatement
et moi malheureusement tout ça c'était
au sens propre moi c'était plus au sens
figuré mais c'est vrai que le parallèle
est assez troublant une fois que je les
réaliser mais je suis très sensible
comme ça au à quoi juste un signe
alors comment les appeler de signe du
destin je sais pas la synchronicité de
certains événements aux choses qui se
parlent qui se répondent peut-être
comment vous l'avez compris ça j'ai
compris en écrivant en fait j'ai ce que
vous racontez d'ailleurs la radio et
votre amour c'était une déclaration
d'amour à la radio et vous racontez
votre trajectoire mais il fallait aussi
ces deux voies là pour faire un livre ça
ne suffisait pas la radio il fallait
raconter cette parent l'histoire ou
essai c'est c'est quand même cette
proximité que jamais cessé entre ma
maman et moi et aller a donc parlé
d'avenir elle alors fragnes à nettoyer
en 1934 donc elle fait partie de ces
femmes sait pas non plus si longtemps
quand il n'aura rien pas de pilule pas
diriger pour le coup pas de péridurale
quand elles accouchent et de ses deux
filles pas tellement droit à la parole
enfin voilà qui donne tout ce qui donne
mon genou et saint alphonse et le même
temps très libre ouais c'est la mort
totale et en même temps elle avait un
sens aigu de sa liberté
peut-être par contraste justement et
donc on sait suivi jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout on sait soutenu et on
partageait aussi une inquiétude
permanente parce que
fran ya quand elle avait 8 ans a échappé
à la rafle du vel d'hiv
c'est à dire que ses parents avaient été
prévenus que les amants elle est bien
aidé par la police française
elle est menée 7 cette rafle et donc la
famille a pu fuir mais chaque comme son
côté les deux petites filles d'à côté
les parents de l'autre et à 8 ans à voir
cette peur initial doublé d'une
séparation de ses parents pendant deux
ans sans nouvelle je pense que l a
toujours gardé ça et ça ne m'étonnerait
pas qu'elle me les transmis donc on
était toujours ça s'appelle
l'épigénétique est intéressant c'est à
dire qu on est on est pas neutre en fait
et on avait une inquiétude permanente
est réciproque
voilà c'était ça notre relation vous
dites plongée dans un monde où deux
silences se font face dans une époque
bruyant c'est ce que j'écrivais oui elle
est présente est sidérant via la
communication qui continue vous
continuer à partager alors que votre
mère ne parle plus elle est consciente
oui elle avait toute sa tête jusqu'au
bout et je sais pas si c'est une chance
pour le coup parce que elle réalisé très
bien qu'elle a fini sa vie dans un lit
malheureusement mais oui on a cessé de
communiquer jusqu'au bout et même de
rire ensemble et on a vécu de très beaux
moments vous savez on parle de fin de
vie mais on sait pas combien de temps ça
dure une fin de vie ses cadres ont fait
qu'on lui fait cette promesse que vous
allez tenir à jamais l'ehpad jamais d
pad jamais de maisons de retraite jamais
d pad d'abord parce que ça n'était pas
son choix et dans un accent un peu
mélodramatique parce que souvent une
échappée pour mélodramatique m'avait dit
que si elle signalait alan moore est
donc voilà je lui ai fait cette promesse
qui a été difficile à tenir
est ce que malheureusement rien n'est
fait pour laisser les gens à domicile et
ça me révolte un peu pour dire la vérité
que voilà on prennent pas soin d de nos
vieux alors je vous renvoie à la lecture
de minutes c'est absolument passionnant
parce que c'est sensible ces
nostalgiques et c'est sur le fil
voilà
voilà ça reste très pudique vous allez
continuer à écrire la radio c'est fini
je sais pas peut-être pas par est décrit
oui j'ai su mer la radio oui mais moi je
quelqu'un de l'oralité j'ai l'impression
même si j'ai beaucoup aimé écrire ce
livre ça a été difficile c'est difficile
d'écrire mais c'est un sentiment ou et
d'aboutissement vraiment très important
et je pense que ça m'a aidé aussi à
apprendre un peu de distance avec tout
ça merci vous restez avec nous parce
qu'à carta s'appelle donc mme ute
neutron lutte comme mutation il ya
beaucoup de choses qui mute les virus
mais pas seulement le monde a beaucoup
muté a quand même donc voilà c'est comme
on veut mute minutes et c'est chez
flammarion va terminer avec une
controverse dans le sillage de la
cérémonie des césars de la polémique
autour du prix à romane polanski deux
tribunes concernant la justice sont
parus à deux jours d'intervalle dans le
monde
en cause la présomption d'innocence face
à la libération de la parole des femmes
sur les violences sexuelles
on voit cela d'abord avec aube aubry
perreault qui nous présente les deux
textes et on en parle avec nos invités
juste après le problème c'est que depuis
les césars fin février et la récompense
décernée à romagne polanski absent ce
jour-là
la polémique ne retombe pas sortie
remarquée de l'actrice adèle haenel le
soir de la cérémonie manifestations
féministes devant la salle parisienne
et tribune fracassante deux jours plus
tard de l'écrivaine virginie despentes
avec ce cri guerre devenue célèbre
désormais on se lève et on se barre
depuis deux semaines artistes et
politiques sont sommés de se positionner
célébrer l'homme est un message est un
signal qui est envoyée il me semble
négativement à un moment où la chape de
plomb sur ces agressions sexuelles et
sexistes est en train d'exploser dans
notre pays peut-on pointé publiquement
du doigt romane polanski accusé de viols
et d'agressions sexuelles
alors que les faits sont prescrits on ne
font pas l'objet de plantes un débat de
société explosif où chacun y va de son
commentaire
florence foresti et adèle haenel
s'improvise juges sont elles plus
compétente pour dire le droit que le
tribunal fédéral suisse
dimanche 8 mars une centaine d'avocats
pénalistes riposte avec cette tribune
publiée dans le monde
il est urgent de considérer la
prescription et le respect de la
présomption d'innocence comme des
instruments d'impunité
réponse cinglante aujourd'hui de
plusieurs personnalités
selon elle les victimes de violences
sexuelles souffrirait d'une présomption
permanente de mensonges
la justice et comme la santé la police
le monde du travail
elle n'est pas neutre
des coups d'éclat médiatiques cette
avocate s'inquiète d'un débat biaisé
pour que le débat avance effectivement
il faut que sois plus apaisé il faut
aussi surtout prendre va chercher où le
bât blesse vrai combat s'est donné les
moyens justement à la justice les
enquêtes ne sont pas fait les preuves ne
sont pas recherchés ne sont pas
conservés et donc souvent des plaintes
sont classées sans suite
alors peut-on encore allonger les délais
de prescription en matière de violences
sexuelles
la chasse aux sorcières publique est
elle légitime lorsque la justice paraît
trop longues ou inefficaces à certains
seule certitude dans ce débat la
difficulté à faire dialoguer des partis
qui semblent irréconciliables
voilà je voudrais qu'on parte peut-être
après sujet de votre tribune frédéric
beaulieu je rappelle que vous êtes 114
avocate pénaliste à l'avoir à l'avoir
signée par ton de la présomption
d'innocence qui fonde le droit pénal
vous pensez qu'elle est bafouée
aujourd'hui dans ce climat particulier
de libération de la parole vous avez
lancé votre sujet en parlant de en dix
ans la présomption d'innocence
en face de la libération de la parole la
présomption d'innocence à un moment oui
la parole des femmes se libère et
parfois accusent ou désigne absolument
certains auteurs jamais jean des
violeurs je crois que notre notre
démarche avec mes consoeurs c'était
justement de ne pas les opposer il n'est
pas question pour nous évidemment je
dire nous sommes 114 avocate
de tous âges de tous âges c'est ça qui
était intéressant aussi de toute
expérience pénaliste donc confrontés à
la fois à la défense des victimes ou des
plaignantes et à la défense également
des auteurs donc avec une expérience
comme ça avec des générations
différentes et ce qu'on voulait si vous
voulez c'était dire que justement la
libération de la parole ne pouvait pas
defacto devenir quelque chose qui allait
mettre à mal des choses qui sont
vraiment des fondements un fondement qui
est vraiment un fondement démocratique
fondamental lui dire ça fait des siècles
on a mis des siècles à arriver à ça à
sortir de la justice privée qui est la
présomption d'innocence
enfin ces substituts elle c'était ça
c'était ça notre idée et je regrette que
ce soit effectivement moi j'aimerais
bien dialogué parce que je vois pas ce
qu'il y'a 10 réconciliables elle vous
parle et d'agrandir l'arrivée dans les
formes de triomphe du tribunal de
l'opinion
oui mais oui parce que nous sommes dans
un pays de droit et que on ne décrète
pas dans l'opinion quelqu'un de coupable
ça c'est la justice privée ça ne va pas
du tout il ya des tribunaux pour ça et
les tribunaux contrairement je crois ce
qu'on dit fonctionne voilà qu'est ce que
vous répondez à leurs milliers koyama
rappelle quand même que vous avez donc
signer cette seconde tribune qui vient
répondre à celle qu'a signé m beaulieu
17 personnalités donc dans le monde qui
évoque une forme d'aveuglément de la
justice et ses dysfonctionnements mais
déjà qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça ne
pas se substituer à la justice
alors je voudrais déjà rappelé un
principe fondamental de l'état d'euros
ce principe fondamental c'est le respect
de la dignité de la personne humaine
dire que dans une société dans un état
de droit on ne viole pas des femmes on
ne viole pas des enfants ne viole pas
personne la personne ne viendra pas sur
internet voilà partant de là partant de
là quelle est la réalité judiciaire à
laquelle sont confrontés les victimes de
violences sexuelles
c'est une réalité judiciaire très dur
c'est 60 à 80% de correctionnalisations
des classements sans suite à n'en plus
finir
donc la réalité c'est que il y à une
injustice pour les victimes de violences
sexuelles et que cette injustice et une
blessure et une entorse à l'état de
droit sur le principe fondamental de la
présomption d'innocence vous le défendez
ce principe on va parler d'injustice
mais si je peux me permettre
les dysfonctionnements de la justice est
ce le même sujet que la présomption
d'innocence
alors est ce que c'est ce que vous
répondez au fond à cette libération de
la bad la parole qui est nécessaire au
risque d'être excessives alors la
présomption d'innocence dans un cadre
judiciaire est un principe essentiel
on parle de deux choses différentes le
dysfonctionnement vous parler
d'ajustement non non non concernant la
présomption d'innocence il a été dit
enfin on parlait cette tribune en
l'occurrence parler de présomption
d'innocence
hors cadre judiciaire est-ce qu'elle a
été piétiné la présomption d'innocence
dans le cadre oman polanski pourrait
très simple alors nous nous menons un
combat sociétal faire que nous exprimons
nous libérons notre parole dans une
démocratie comme les femmes et les
victimes ont le droit de le faire
voilà et en plus ce n'est pas un combat
contre la justice que nous menons mais
pour réclamer justice
donc concernant romane polanski il ya un
gros problème c'est à dire que on il ya
eu plusieurs débats séparer l'homme de
l'artiste etc
mais déjà je vais rappeler ce que ce que
beaucoup de personnes savent c'est qu'en
l'occurrence il a été condamné
il a fui les états unis donc la justice
est appliquée et d'autre part concernant
j'accuse 1 il s'est servi quelque part
d'une figure historique pour se
victimiser donc quelque part lui n'a pas
séparer l'homme de l'artiste
je veux dire donc nous on est monté au
créneau parce que le symbole c'est le
prix qui vous est de récompenser un
un pour nous pédocriminels fugitif a
profondément blessé les victimes et vous
vous ne voyez pas de présomption de
culpabilité dans le débat public sur
roman polanski
c'est le sujet encore une fois la
présomption d'innocence dans un cadre
judiciaire
là on parle d'autres la société on parle
de toutes ces femmes dont voit la mer
qui ont mis des siècles à libérer leur
parole et qui sait que ça rigolait c'est
la société et contre la justice
oui mais justement ça marche pas comme
ça ça marche pas comme ça
c'est tribunal n'avait pas pour objet
romane polanski c'est pas notre sujet
vraiment pas notre sujet c'est quoi
c'est de dire que la libération de la
parole
d'une certaine manière avec cette
position qui est la vôtre qui consiste à
dire que la justice ne peut pas répondre
que c'est un combat sociétale et que
justice elle est tellement insuffisantes
elles marchent pas et c est que ça ne
marchera pas vous arriver à une
situation où à mon avis au lieu de
libérer la parole des femmes quelque
part vous les enfermer dans une position
de victime
non seulement de leurs violeurs de celui
qui a commis un crime épouvantable pense
qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus mais
vous les enfermer dans une position qui
est que personne ne pourra les entendre
et que le l'état le droit les tribunaux
nous les accueillerons pas vous dites
dans votre tribune que présumer la bonne
foi et là on parle de droit présumé la
bonne foi de toutes les femmes se
déclarant victimes de violences
sexuelles reviendrait à sacraliser
arbitrairement leur parole oui parce que
cette idée que parce qu'une femme accuse
c'est nécessairement exact c'est faux
comme de n'importe quelle parole la
justice elle est là pour et c'est son
rôle et c'est son fonctionnement et on
peut sans honorer
elle est là pour vérifier les choses
pour regarder s'il ya des preuves s'il
n'y a pas de preuve le juge vous savez
il est pas dans la pièce où le viol a eu
lieu le juge il a besoin pour former sa
conviction de preuves d'éléments de
témoins et c'est aussi et je termine une
des raisons pour lesquelles
l'allongement indéfinie de la
prescription pour ce crime là ne peut
pas être utile
appel que vous éditez pour au fond
l'imprescribilité des crimes des crimes
sexuels voudrais vous faire réagir sur
ce débat là alors certes quelques
largesses d'un débat très complexe je
sais bien qu'il ya deux camps et combien
du mal à dialoguer je suis d'accord avec
vous m la justice enfin le will la
vindicte populaire ne doit pas se
substituer à la justice et tous ces cas
doivent se régler devant les tribunaux
mais ça c'est dans un monde merveilleux
c'est dans un monde merveilleux on sait
bien et à dia des faits contrairement à
ce que vous dites
la justice ne fonctionne pas pourquoi
est-ce cadalen elle elle ne porte pas
plainte au début elle a fini par le
faire parce qu'elle a terminé à ce
qu'elle fait ce constat là et à la
raison ce constat est étayée tous les
jours si la justice alors la sangle sur
le dysfonctionnement l'éclatement des
flèches mètres à beaulieu pas formés
pour ça alors deux choses la première
c'est que si vous me dites pour la
justice plus de moyens plus de policiers
formés plus de personnes pour recueillir
la parole plus de mes traites 70% des
plaintes pour violence sexuelle son
cabinet sa fuite mardi notamment si l'on
me dit ça évidemment oui qui ne qui peut
ne pas avoir envie que la justice
fonctionne mieux
si par contre vous me dites il est
établi que la justice en matière
spécifique de violences faites aux
femmes ne fonctionne pas parce qu'elle
serait et c'est que discours qui est
tenu par mature si je puis dire contre
cet examen est je crois que ce soit jeu
long et dense et ajuste un génie sna
mais c'est pas volé les magistrats ne
sont ne sont pas formés on a vu des
procès récemment avec des
interrogatoires qui était hallucinant il
n'y a pas de formation mais il ya des
programmes de la parole pour l'égalité
est loin et puis apporter la preuve
qu'on a été violée ou violent mais c'est
souvent parole contre parole
alors que le juge laisse les années
les décennies de sidération c'est pas si
facile de parler en fait on dit il faut
parler oui la victime doit parler c'est
pas évident et toutes les femmes j'en
termine tous les fans mais avant d'en
voler souvent l'on sait pas quelles ont
regretté
mais ça a été horrible pour elle nicolas
mas et vous aurez le mot de la fin
j'avais vont juste sur le fait que nous
disons que la justice ne peut pas
répondre violences sexuelles nous disons
nous parlons juste la réalité celle
qu'on vient d'évoquer c'est à dire ces
classements sans suite cette
correctionnalisation la charge qui pèse
la justice demande beaucoup à la victime
de violences sexuelles elle demande
beaucoup et ça c'est la réalité et si il
y à si peu de victimes qui porte plainte
en particulier des victimes de violences
sexuelles sur mineures je rappelle que
ces 4 % c'est que le système est
extrêmement difficile avec les victimes
et d'autres pour résumer vous mais
peut-être d'accord il faut respecter le
droit de tous les justiciables et faire
en sorte que la justice dans son
fonctionnement
concernant ces violences sexuelles
s'améliore j'ajoute aussi que on ne
s'enferme pas pour terre dans un statut
de victime du tout ont en revanche on se
barre pour l'évolution de la loi
l'évolution de la loi et la
reconnaissance et il ya des missions
parlementaires et c'est à la salle art
national d'ailleurs comme savaient
qu'ils sont qui sont en cours on
s'arrête là c'est un débat difficile et
un débat complexe merci en tout cas
c'est extrêmement clair va terminer avec
allez je ne sais pas si le sujet est
vraiment plus léger en tout cas c'est
valérie brochard qui vient nous raconter
sa journée un peu particulière à
l'assemblée où valérie ce soir comme
vous le voyez myriam il y a absolument
personne ici à l'assemblée nationale et
c'est normal c'est la trêve
parlementaire pour les élections
municipales mais il ya aussi plusieurs
personnes ici à l'assemblée nationale
qui ont contracté le coronavirus je vais
vous expliquer ça en plateau tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir valérie alors que se passe-t-il
à l'assemblée deux attendent deux agents
ont été atteint de deux agents et
plusieurs députés exactement myriam le
virus a pénétré le palais bourbon alors
les fameux gestes barrières s'impose hop
une petite dose de gel hydroalcoolique
voilà on se frotte bien les mains et
comme ça on peut poursuivre la chronique
ils sont 5 5 députés contaminées par le
virus
on va les découvrir ensemble à l'image
jean luc reitzer député les républicains
du haut-rhin membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères il ya aussi
elisabeth toutu picard et lui les
républicains également mais cette fois
dans la circonscription de la haute
garonne angoisse un peu votre j'ai pas
trop aimé les livres et vu un socialiste
la première dans la sarthe et la seconde
dans l'ardèche d'ailleurs par précaution
vous le voyez le porte-parole du ps et
député boris vallot s'est mis en
quarantaine puisqu'il a dîné avec ses
deux collègues et puis et puis le
dernier élu aux contaminés s'appelle
guillaume guyot tu es députés la
république en marge du val d'oise alors
il a publié ce message sur twitter j'ai
été testé ce samedi positif au
coronavirus je suis chez moi confinés
pendant 14 jours à ceux qui m'ont croisé
cette semaine ne pas céder à la psychose
mais bien respecté les gestes barrières
et son fils au freinage de la
propagation
on le rappelle le coude et puis un petit
peu de regrets comment faire entrer
alors d'aider le 6 mars myriam le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
bien surpris et transmis certaines
mesures regardé comme proposé du
télétravail à tous les collaborateurs
qui auraient approché ces fameux député
contaminée est fermée tous les
restaurants de l'assemblée pour
désinfection voilà pas de cantine
pendant quinze jours myriam voilà pour
l'assemblée puis côté elysée bien le
directeur du cabinet d' emmanuel macron
à patrick strzoda a été en contact avec
un porteur de la maladie alors lui va
bien
mais par précaution il se tient à
l'écart du président et puis vous savez
notre ministre de la culture est aussi
infectée franck riester il va dire
exactement il a voulu rassurer vous avez
raison mais rien avec ce message j'ai
été diagnostiqué positif au corona virus
je travaille depuis mon demi
il en lien avec mon cabinet et les
équipes du ministère je remercie très
sincèrement toutes celles et ceux qui
m'ont témoigné leur soutien et leur
amitié bon vous le voyez myriam ici pas
de panique pas de psychose les choses
sont plutôt prise en main avec sérieux
et sérénité nous voilà donc rassurés en
tout cas je l'espère mais mais vous le
savez il est un moyen aussi très très
efficace en pour résister à la panique
et bien c'est l'humour
alors j'ai quelques initiatives à vous
montrer tout d'abord ce chocolatier du
finistère qui fait un véritable carton
avec son show coronavirus il a tout
simplement reproduit le virus en
chocolat et il en vend des dizaines et
puis ces vidéos évidemment qui font le
tour de la toile le fameux foot chèque
pour éviter de se serrer la main europe
on se salue pied contre-pied et puis ces
cases ces cases déniché par les
internautes dans l'album astérix et la
transit à licques sorti en 2010 est où
les héros gaulois affronte un pilote
romain baptisé le mas viel veut faire
coroner au navire eurent à la fin de la
course de chars myriam astérix et obélix
gagne et coronavirus père en espérant
que cette bd soit prémonitoire en tout
cas on l'espère on l'espère aussi
immersive à l'exercie à vous merci
pascal car la venue sur le plateau mais
c'est drôle d'époque belle soirée avant
à demain
[Musique]